today we look at the surface area and
the volume of a sphere this is how we
can draw a sphere the dotted portion is
what cannot be seen from the front view
and this is the center of the sphere and
let R be its radius don't forget every
point on the sphere is equidistant from
its center how do we define the surface
area of the sphere the surface area of
the sphere equals to 4 PI R squared
a sphere has just one type of surface
area its total surface area is its
curved surface area as it does not have
any flat surfaces and the volume of the
sphere is given as 4 by 3 PI R cubed at
the moment
we do not need to know how we arrived
here the formulae but we will cover this
topic for sure in one of our videos of
higher grade mathematics if we know the
formula for a sphere we can easily
derive the formulae for a hemisphere 2
and what is a hemisphere a hemisphere is
half a sphere let's say it has a radius
R we have just got the sphere
horizontally and we are looking at the
bottom part the best way to understand
the hemisphere is by looking at the
earth the equator divides the earth into
two hemispheres the Northern Hemisphere
and the southern hemisphere if we split
the earth at the equator we get two
hemispheres like these ok great let's
get back to a figure now what do you
notice looking at the hemisphere the
first thing you should notice is that it
has a flat surface
and a curved surface this tells us that
unlike the sphere the hemisphere will
have a different curved surface area and
total surface area let's look at the
curved surface area first looking at
both the figures we can easily say that
it will be half that of the surface area
of the sphere
dividing this by two we get two PI R
square that's the curved surface area
what about the total surface area the
total surface area will be the sum of
the area of the curved surface and the
area of the circle on top we have
figured the area of the curved surface
to be 2 PI R squared the area of the
circle on top will be PI R squared
adding these two we get 3 PI R squared
so the curved surface area is 2 PI R
squared and the total surface area is 3
PI R squared what about its volume again
the volume of the hemisphere will be
exactly half that of the volume of the
sphere dividing this by 2 we get 2 by 3
PI R cubed
you